Julie is in Memphis hi Julie how are you
I'm great how are you doing better than
I deserve what's up thanks for letting
me ask this okay I want your advice and
opinion on the situation my father
passed away last month and we basically
didn't have a relationship has high
school he never took the role of being a
father pretty much so as his daughter of
course I feel responsible for the cost
associated with the cremation which was
his wish his oldest brother had power of
attorney and he along with his other
brother beggars paid everything to date
so I've mentioned feeling responsible
and offering to pay although I have not
been asked for any money I've just been
told that it's my decision and I would
just like to know your your take on this
as far as morally I just feel like
that's something I should do hmm I'm
trying to put myself in your shoes
because that's how I answer questions
and how long has it been since you've
had contact with your dad before he
passed how many years of separation
spoke with him prior to his passing
because I was being asking questions but
of course I could not answer because
neither my sister nor myself have
actually had a relationship with him and
it was pretty long ago how long ago he
leave your life
well I'm 46 so pretty much since I was
18 the only time I really seen him is 25
years yeah okay quite a while yeah and
and how much is the bill for the
cremation 2200 right and what is
national income I'm right at 72 I'm
single
I you have denim baby step for all I
have is my mortgage all right do you
want to pay it I have mixed emotions
about it but I do feel like let me help
let me give you I'll give you my opinion
it's not your obligation okay if you
want to pay it pay it there's nothing
wrong with it but I wouldn't lay awake
one minute about not paying it 25 years
this is the Dave Ramsey show